it began with a distant sighting and a
desperate mayday call
me
15 men overboard approximately 15 man
overboard
when rescuers arrived this was all that
was left of the boat a twisted piece of
deflated plastic adrift in very cold
water
charles devos was one of the first
people there he pulled a series of
bodies from the water
within hours he was back at work with
the calais lifeboat crew
still affected by his view of a hellish
disaster
la vie des
[Music]
but still people attempt this perilous
crossing here gathered together at
calais main train station dozens of
migrants who had tried and failed to
cross the channel
these people are soaking wet they're
covered in mud and they're wearing
drenched life jackets this is evidence
that even in the wake of tragedy there
is still a long stream of people
desperate to cross from france
over to the united kingdom
these people are living in camps and in
rough shelters there is no comfort for
any of them their one aim is to cross
the channel
we meet hassan aware of the tragedy but
still wholly focused upon reaching the
uk
i heard the news my life to be very
honest
by myself i don't care about others
because it's my own life
even i see the water i can swim if i put
my wasp in my jacket i can swim you're
honest i want to go to uk because my
life is there will be very good
this camp is cold and miserable the
effects of cross-channel migration can
be seen in both britain and france and
both countries think the other one
should be doing more
the french have called for a meeting of
ministers in calais on sunday and today
speaking in croatia the french president
urged greater actions
has become synonymous with migration and
political rows that seem to go nowhere
this town and its people are weary they
will continue to to to die in the sea or
under the tracks
the the the situation is deadly they can
also die of of the cold
the police operation here continues so
many people have predicted this disaster
now nobody can say that it won't happen
again adam parsons sky news kelly